damen und herren wir verlassen ein
weiteres mal den bundestag vorübergehend
zu robert habeck dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister mit neuen
informationen zur energieversorgung im
land
cd 1
ja schönen guten tag herzlich willkommen
zu der pressekonferenz mit
bundesminister robert habeck zur
energieversorgungssicherheit
wir haben knapp 45 minuten im anschluss
gibt es noch einen hintergrund mit
staatssekretär reichen und klaus müller
chef der bundesnetzagentur wo sie noch
mal vertieft auch fragen stellen können
für diejenigen die daran teilnehmen und
so viel vorab bundesminister robert
habeck hartes wort
vielen dank guten morgen von meiner
seite wir haben zu dieser
pressekonferenz eingeladen um sie
darüber zu informieren dass wir nach
abstimmung in der bundesregierung
gestern und nach informationen der
europäischen partner heute jetzt in
diesem moment die alarmstufe gas
ausrufen wir haben in deutschland eine
störung der gasversorgung so ist es
definiert daher ist es erforderlich
diese alarmstufe auszurufen
gas ist von nun an ein knappes gut in
deutschland das sage ich obwohl oder
gerade weil die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland aktuell gewährleistet ist
der markt ist also in der lage die
mengen die benötigt werden um die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland zu
gewährleisten und auch die speicher
moderat anzufüllen auf dem markt zu
besorgen
dennoch und das zwingt uns zu diesem
schritt heute
darf die aktuelle lage uns nicht in eine
falsche sicherheit in einer falschen
sicherheit werden wir haben nachdem in
der letzten woche russland gazprom unter
einem vorgeschobenen technischen
argument die gaslieferungen auf der nord
stream pipeline um 60 prozent reduziert
hat verschiedene szenarien
durchgerechnet diese szenarien
zeige ich ihnen einmal
das ist nämlich ich finde sehr
anschaulich zu sehen wo man da gerade
steht die roten punkte sind die
gesetzlich vorgegebenen speicher soll
füllstände die blaue kurve also quasi
der optimale verlauf unter der annahme
von einer reduktion von north um 61
prozent also die minus 40 prozent ist
die kurve die wir erreichen sollen sie
ist allerdings nur möglich zu erreichen
unter der annahme dass wir nicht für das
europäische nachbarland aus speichern
das ist erstens ungesetzlich und
zweitens wäre es auch hat sucht weil wir
ja darauf angewiesen sind dass die
europäischen länder uns beliefern also
niederlande norwegen benelux belgien
frankreich
alle diese länder
brauchen wir ja um überhaupt über
energie gas gas nach deutschland zu
bekommen insofern und das ist die
not das ist die erkenntnis die uns zu
diesem tag führt scheidet diese kurve
per logik und per gesetz aus bleiben die
verschiedenen anderen szenarien und sie
sehen hier ist die nulllinie hier sind
die speicher leer dass die meisten
szenarien uns sehr weit in die zone von
lehrern speichern führen deswegen greift
die definition des gesetzes ich brauche
mir sich einmal vorzulesen die
alarmstufe wird dann ausgerufen wenn
eine störung der gasversorgung oder eine
außergewöhnlich hohe nachfrage nach gas
vorliegt die zu einer erheblichen
verschlechterung der gas versorgungslage
führt den markt aber noch in der lage
ist diese störung oder nachfrage zu
bewältigen ohne das nicht mag basierte
maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen dieser
fall liegt vor wir haben uns die paar
tage zeit gelassen die szenarien
durchzurechnen das ist kein spiel wir
müssen einen so gravierenden schritt gut
gründen können und die begründung ist
aus meiner sicht schlagend
wir sind also jetzt gehalten die
gasverbraucher zu reduzieren jetzt im
sommer dann vor allem mit der
perspektive auf den winter und das ist
sicherlich
die trügerische wirklichkeit in der wir
uns im moment bewegen es ist sommer und
zwar ein sommer nach einer langen
pandemie zeit mein will gerne draußen
die zeit genießen man will auch
vielleicht mal ohne politische trübsal
im kopf die zeit genießen aber der
winter wird ja kommen wir müssen also
jetzt die vorsorge treffen um dann im
winter vorbereitet zu sein und alles
daran setzen dass wir mit vollen
speicherstände in den winter gehen
ich will ausdrücklich unterstreichen
dass diese situation ja immer eine
bedrohung war und so hat sich die
bundesregierung seit amtsantritt seit
dezember auf dieses szenario vorbereitet
wir haben früh angefangen alternative
infrastrukturen zu schaffen die lng
terminals mit hochgeschwindigkeit zu
bauen beziehungsweise die pipeline
anschluss zu bauen für die fsa user für
diversifizierung schiffe wir haben früh
angefangen mit steuergeld gasmengen zu
besorgen und über den winter zu kommen
bzw
die
kapazitäten die nicht durch den markt
befüllt werden aufzufüllen das schließt
auch den speicher reden den gast kaum
speicher reden mit ein wir haben die
verschiedenen gesetze geschrieben die es
uns jetzt ermöglichen auch
gesetzgeberisch tätig zu werden das gas
einspeicherung gesetz das energie
sicherungs gesetz all die gesetze zum
ausbau der erneuerbaren die sich jetzt
in der parlamentarischen beratung
befinden die also dann die energiemenge
hoffentlich zeitnah erhöhen
ich will und ich muss an dieser stelle
sagen dass sich natürlich auch recht
dass wir in den letzten jahren in
deutschland nicht gut genug waren es
sind die versäumnisse der letzten dekade
die uns jetzt in dieser bedrängnis
geführt haben und damit meine ich nicht
nur die politisch falsche abhängigkeit
von russland sondern auch die fehlende
bereitschaft alternativen zu schaffen
wie anders ständen wir da wenn wir die
letzten jahre in der energieeffizienz
und dem ausbau der erneuerbaren wirklich
massiv voran gekommen wären statt
einfach nur im stillstand zu verharren
das rächt sich jetzt und muss mit großer
geschwindigkeit aufgeholt werden
dass das nicht von heute auf morgen geht
es allen klar aber von heute auf
übermorgen sollte erreichbar sein um
dieses übermorgen zu erreichen sind wir
gezwungen maßnahmen zu treffen die
wirklich weh tun wir haben sie schon am
wochenende angekündigt zu nennen sind
dass wir die
kohlekraftwerke aus der reserve in den
betrieb bringen werden um somit gas vom
markt zu nehmen gas für die
elektrifizierung vom markt zu nehmen um
dieses gas dann ein speichern zu können
wir werden ein gas spa auktionsmodell
vorliegen das ist der industrie noch mal
erlaubt gegen geld ein um eine
umlagefinanzierung
gasverbraucher aus dem betrieb zu nehmen
und gestern hat nach beratungen im
haushaltsausschuss der gesetzgeber 15
milliarden euro für den markt
gebietsverantwortlichen also trading
europe das ist der die tochter
unternehmer der gasnetzbetreiber 15
milliarden euro freizugeben um gas
einzukaufen für die weitere speicherung
die alarmstufe gesetzlich gebotenen nach
den analysen die wir haben ist außerdem
die grundlage für weitere schritte und
die werden wir gehen sobald die gesetze
verabschiedet sind beziehungsweise
sobald die notwendigkeit es gebietet
zwei beispiele will ich nehme einmal im
parlamentarischen verfahren befindet
sich in der endabstimmung das
kraftwerksbereich haltungs gesetz
dieses gesetz ist dann die grundlage
dafür dass wir die kohlekraftwerke rein
nehmen können es wird wenn der bundestag
so dieses gesetz verabschiedet wie
geplant dann am 8.7 den bundesrat
passieren und dann werden die verordnung
vorliegen die teilweise an die ausrufung
der alarmstufe gebunden sind die
verordnung werden jetzt unter hochdruck
geschrieben und die kraftwerksbetreiber
die dann mit den verordnungen
[Musik]
ihre kohlekraftwerke in den markt
bringen sind angeschrieben worden dass
es so kommen wird die werden also jetzt
schon die kohle bereitstellen die
kraftwerke wieder flott machen für den
einsatz dann in zweieinhalb wochen
zweite was ich nennen will und was immer
mit der alarmstufe auch öffentlich
verknüpft wurde ist der paragraph 24
energie sicherungs gesetz in sich es ist
der paragraph für die weitergabe von
preisen auch außerhalb der verträge
erlaubt er ist an die voraussetzung der
alarmstufe gebunden aber es gibt kein
automatismus und deswegen der ihnen wie
ihn heute nicht ziehen noch nicht
ausrufen der grund ist dass wir den
markt weiter beobachten wollen die
beziehung des paragrafen 24n sieg ist
daran gebunden dass die
bundesnetzagentur eine weitere störung
und zwar eine strukturelle störung der
gas flüsse festgestellt deswegen werden
wir haben wir die voraussetzung jetzt
hier mit geschaffen werden aber heute
noch nicht ausrufen
damit bin ich beim preis denn paragraf
24 m sieg würde eine preis weitergabe
der gas betreiber außerhalb der verträge
bedeuten diese preise werden zu tragen
seien von der wirtschaft von den
verbrauchern und von den verbrauchern
und unabhängig davon ob man 24 1 6 oder
nicht die preise kommen bei den
verbraucherinnen und bei den
verbrauchern an das was wir also hier im
moment erleben ist eine extreme
belastung für viele menschen für viele
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer diese
belastung ist ein externer schock es ist
ja nicht die
schlüssigkeit der deutschen
volkswirtschaft die uns zu dieser
situation geführt hat sondern der krieg
in russland und durch den krieg und
durch die politisch induzierte
verknappung von fossilen rohstoffen
die die der druck der im land aufgebaut
wurde diese preise müssen also getragen
werden dass sie fair getragen werden und
das ist entsprechend entlastung gibt für
die haushalte und für die unternehmen
die sich nicht leisten können das ist
die aufgabe der nächsten wochen das gut
zu analysieren und dort abhilfe bzw
unterstützung zu schaffen bleibt als
letztes zu sagen dass wir obwohl es
sommer ist alle einen beitrag leisten
können die unternehmerin und die
unternehmer in dem sie schauen welche
einsparpotenziale noch da sind und ich
weiß dass sie das tun es gibt
berechnungen ist der gasverbrauch in der
deutschen industrie in den letzten
monaten ungefähr acht prozent
zurückgegangen ist
aber auch privathaushalte können ein
unterschied jetzt schon machen ich weiß
dass es manchmal banal klingt aber diese
banalität muss man immer mit 41
millionen haushalten multiplizieren und
bevor der winter kommt macht es eben
sinn die heizung noch einmal vernünftig
einzustellen oder einen hydraulischen
abgleich durchzuführen und die summen an
energie wie auch an geld die dort zu
sparen sind sind durchaus
erheblich bis zu 15 prozent
beispielsweise an
heizkostenersparnis kann man machen nur
durch den hydraulischen abgleich also
nur dadurch dass die heizung vernünftig
eingestellt sind und das wäre dann ja
entsprechend die energiemenge und das
nehmen wir jetzt mit 41 millionen
haushalten multipliziert und dann sieht
man dass die kleinen teilweise so
belächelten annalen schritte in der
summe dann doch einen großen unterschied
machen diesen unterschied müssen wir
aber machen wir befinden uns in einer
ökonomischen auseinandersetzung mit
russland gas und energie wird als waffe
gegen deutschland eingesetzt aus meiner
sicht mit dem ziel das was das land in
den letzten wochen und monaten
ausgezeichnet hat und europa
ausgezeichnet hat zu zerstören nämlich
eine große geschlossenheit eine große
solidarität mit der ukraine und eine
große bereitschaft für die verteidigung
von freiheit auch einen preis zu zahlen
über die preis der watte soll genau dies
zerstört werden das wiederum darf nicht
passieren deswegen müssen alle
politischen maßnahmen ergriffen werden
dass wir genug gas haben wie eben
ausgeführt dass die lasten in
deutschland fair verteilt werden aber
nicht dass das land in einen zustand
gerät wie wir ihn auch an anderen
stellen schon hatten wo wir nicht über
die richtigkeit von verschiedenen
maßnahmen streiten sondern darüber
streiten und für nicht putin seinen
sehen lassen sollen das wäre fatal und
deswegen ist das was wir hier gerade
machen eine kollektive eine nationale
kraftanstrengung die wir nur gemeinsam
bestehen werden vielen dank
vielen dank ich habe die ersten fragen
ich fange an im raum herr delfs dann ja
kummer und frau herzog wir machen eine
frage nach der anderen also frage
antwort wenn es am ende knapp mit der
zeit bin ich aber erstmal ohne hair days
bitte herr mir ist können sie ganz kurz
noch mal erklären mit der preisbildung
also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe
werden ja die konsumenten jetzt erstmal
die preiserhöhung gar nicht zu spüren
bekommen richtig sondern das ist ja eine
preisbildung erstmal am markt
stattfindet das heißt die gasunternehmen
siegers lieferanten erfahren diese
preissteigerung aber aber nicht erst mal
die konsumenten weil das wird nicht
weitergegeben ab welchem punkt wird es
weiter geben können sie das noch mal
kurz erklären und warum wird es jetzt
noch nicht weitergehen noch mal ganz
kurz für dumme
ganz so ist es nicht die preise werden
ja weitergegeben wenn sie
zeichnungen geschaut haben werden sie
vermutlich gesehen haben dass uns ist
die abschlagszahlung für das nächste
jahr schon angehoben wurden und zwar je
nach gas oder energieversorger deutlich
also da sind tatsächlich steigerung von
200 prozent zu verzeichnen und manchmal
mehr und das ist ein rollierendes system
die verträge werden in der regel
jährlich angepasst einige stadtwerke
oder versorger machen jetzt schon höhere
abschläge
aber die preisvergabe erfolgt schritt
für schritt je nach stadtgebiet oder
nach haushalt schon jetzt davon
abgesetzt ist der paragraph 24 n sieg
der die preis weitergabe in den
bestehenden verträgen quasi sofort
ermöglicht der hintergrund ist dass die
versorgungsunternehmen
laufende verträge haben
die in der regel oder je nachdem wie
abhängig die von russischem gas sind das
jetzt ja blockiert wird und dann auf dem
gasmarkt auf dem spot-markt neu besorgt
werden muss zu deutlich höheren preisen
je nachdem welche verträge sie haben
machen sie mit jedem tag mit jeder woche
ein - und sollte dieses - so groß werden
dass die unternehmen ist nicht mehr
tragen können und sie umfallen droht der
gesamte markt irgendwann umzufallen also
einen basiseffekt im energiesystem die
versorger wie die stadtwerke nicht mehr
die stadtwerke nicht mehr die
nachgelagerten kunden und dann kann man
sich vorstellen was dann in deutschland
passiert dafür ist der 24 m sieg gedacht
aber eben wie gesagt noch nicht gezogen
weil wir schauen wollen wie sich die
situation weiterentwickelt dieser
paragraph er ist noch nicht das
schärfste schwert das für politisch in
der hand haben aber ein doch so scharfe
schwert dass es mit großem bedacht und
großer gedacht angewandt werden muss
dann bitte an herrn meier
ja wenn wir schon beim § 24 sind sehen
wir gesagt dass in der presseaussendung
das ist eine verstetigung der gasmenge
lage dann eine anzeige durch die
bundesnetzagentur im bundesanzeiger
erforderlich machen würde das wäre ja
dann wenn der paragraf 24 in kraft
treten würde nach meinem verständnis
jetzt ist die frage wenn aus nord stream
1 nachdem wartungen im juli kein gas
mehr kommen wird wird dann der paragraf
24 zum einsatz kommen
ich möchte nicht über den zeitpunkt
spekulieren so wie wir arbeiten das
haben sie ja eben gesehen werden wir
immer die grundlagen analysieren um dann
die vorbereiteten nächsten schritte zu
dienen aber sie haben im der
nebenbemerkung ein erwartbares und
einfach auf deutschland zukommen das
datum angesprochen am elften 7 wird die
neueste mainz pipeline etatmäßig
gewartet diese wartungszeit hat in den
letzten jahren ungefähr zehn tage
gedauert in diesen zehn tagen wird kein
gas über noski mainz nach deutschland
fließen und entsprechend der frage wie
jetzt
effizienzmaßnahmen wirken wie wir
energie gas auf dem weltmarkt besorgen
können und die sich die einspeicherung
bis dahin entwickeln
verschlimmert sich im grunde dann in
dieser situation die lage und sollte es
nicht wieder angemacht werden die
anschlüsse angekommen dann kann man ja
sich ausrechnen die grafik hoch gehalten
dass wir jetzt bei 40 aus dem belastung
noch ein speichern können wenn die noch
wegfallen werden würde es entsprechend
weiterer maßnahmen erforderlich machen
ein kurzer hinweis wir werden im laufe
des tages die grafik und die
dahinterliegende berechnungen auf
veröffentlichen insofern können sie da
gerne auch noch nachschauen frau herzog
bitte haben sie schon super dann waren
die kollegen superschnell
dann vielleicht doch auch werk wegfallen
wird
alle länder die in der gasförderung sind
versuchen die kapazitäten zu erhöhen das
tun sie aus der solidarität heraus aber
natürlich auch weil die preise immens
sind also es ist durchaus lukrativ im
moment gas auf den markt zu bringen die
betonung liegt sicherlich auch auf den
moment das ist sicherlich ein
ausnahmezustand der so auf dauer nicht
bleiben wird das problem ist halt das
gasfelder zu entwickeln beziehungsweise
die kapazitäten zu steigern nicht so
ganz trivial ist man kann hier und da
noch bcm vielleicht zwei oder drei mehr
produzieren aber nicht auf schnitt große
gasfelder erschließen das dauert dann 2
drei jahre oder 34 jahre
trotzdem bemühen sich alle länder das zu
tun und das funktioniert auch wir haben
gesehen dass aus den anderen ländern
größere gasmengen auf den markt gebracht
werden usa kanada norwegen
israel ägypten algerien alle tun ihren
beitrag und das sind die lieferanten
quellen die die dann genutzt werden vom
markt also was wir machen können was ich
machen kann muss die bundesregierung
macht dass diese länder zu ermutigen sie
anzusprechen die situation zu erklären
und die verträge werden aber ja nicht
von uns gemacht sondern dann von den
energieversorgungsunternehmen die sich
dann das günstigste gas auf dem markt
besorgen um dann ihren verpflichtungen
nachzukommen
dann würde ich jetzt einmal in den
digitalen raum wechseln jana wolf bitte
danach herr lochner und dann herr
wiedemann frau wolff sie machen den
anfang
vielen dank hallo herr habegger kabel
ich würde gerne nochmal bei den
entlastungen
nachfahren sie sprachen von extremen
belastungen für viele menschen
unternehmen und unternehmern und das ist
die aufgabe der nächsten wochen sein
wird für eine faire aufteilung zu sorgen
was ist denn da an konkreten schritten
schon angedacht
inwiefern hat das so einem
koalitionsausschuss eine rolle gespielt
und was bedeutet dass perspektivisch für
das ziel eines ausgeglichenen haushalts
und die einhaltung der schuldenbremse
vielen dank
der bundeskanzler hat die konzertierte
aktion einberufen
das ist eine antwort auf die
makroökonomische herausforderung die wir
haben hohe inflation die
mit allen mitteln die wir zur verfügung
haben nicht zu einer rezession werden
darf also das verhindert wird dass es
eine lohn-preis-spirale gibt hohe
inflation führt nach jeder denkbaren
form dazu dass man höhere lohnforderung
hat der verlust muss ja ausgeglichen
werden jugendförderung führen zu noch
höheren preisen führen zu einer noch
höheren inflation und so weiter und so
fort das ist mit den
arbeitgebervertretern mit den
gewerkschaften vor gesprochen worden
dass diese situation die dann aus der
hohen inflation einer rezession machen
kann zu verhindert werden muss und wie
man sie verhindern kann das ist teil der
gespräche die der bundeskanzler führen
wird und die dann ja anfang juli
stattfinden werden dem möchte ich nicht
vorgreifen schon gar nicht würde ich die
zerstören indem ich das spiel mitmachen
das so gerne gespielt wird jeder hat
seine vorschläge auf dem markt und dann
werden die zerredet und am ende ist es
eine machtprobe zwischen parteien
welcher vorschlag dann am besten raus
kommt ich glaube hier muss man
tatsächlich mal ein bisschen von ihm ihr
zurückhaltung üben und damit der
sinnvollste vorschlag oder die besten
die dänen dann auch überhaupt nur eine
chance zu haben umgesetzt zu werden
das interessante damit will ich
schließen ist das und das ist eine nicht
schließen würden diese frage noch
beantworten das ist eine erfindung sehr
hoffnungsvolle erkenntnis ist dass die
klarheit der außergewöhnlichen situation
in der wir uns befinden bei arbeitgebern
den industrievertretern im mittelstand
händlern wie bei den gewerkschaften und
den arbeitnehmervertreterinnen voll da
ist und das die analyse auch eine sehr
gleiche ist denn
selbst oder gerade die arbeitgeber haben
ja kein interesse an einer schwächung
der kaufkraft bei gestörten lieferketten
und blockierten exportmärkten das ist
natürlich zentral wichtig dass die
deutsche binnennachfrage erhalten bleibt
also gibt es ein interesse der
arbeitgeber an einem erhalten der
kaufkraft umgekehrt haben natürlich die
arbeitnehmer die
gewerkschaftsvertreterin kein interesse
dass deutschland ein und attraktiver
standort wird und branchen industrien
geschlossen werden oder abwandern also
gibt es quasi eine spiegel gleiche
erkenntnis der situation und wie die
aufgelöst werden soll wie man auch
politisch helfen kann sie aufzulösen das
wird hoffentlich dann in einem
vertrauten rahmen gegenstand der
gespräche der konzertierten aktion sein
dann wird der herr lochner
hat nicht sie haben das
auktions und gewinnt um damit die
industrie sozusagen zum gas sparen
angeheizt wird da ist jetzt ja der
zeitraum im sommer angegeben vielleicht
können sie das noch ein bisschen mehr
einen grenzen den zeitraum und was hören
sie denn aus der industrie zu
bereitschaft an diesem modell dann auch
tatsächlich teilzunehmen danke
die industrie
ist sehr bereit dieses modell anzunehmen
und setzt da ein stück weit drauf und
unterstützt uns auch bei der
zusammenstellung der daten also das ist
ein instrument das hoffentlich eine
gewisse wirkung und wenn man eine große
hoffnung hat mehr als eine gewisse
wirkung erzielen kann gas verbräuche zu
reduzieren ist natürlich jetzt schon
durch den preisdruck eigentlich das
gebot der stunde in das tun auch viele
ich habe die zahlen genannt
geis für gasverbraucher zu reduzieren
ist aber natürlich auch mit kosten
möglicherweise verursacht wenn die dann
erworben werden können oder ausgeglichen
werden können indem man geld dafür
bekommt wird es noch mal attraktiver
dort einzusteigen also die industrie ist
der ihm sehr sehr aufgeschlossen
gegenüber dass wir das modell erst im
sommer an den start bringen können liegt
wie so weit so viel daran das ist keine
vorbereitung dafür gab als ich ankam ich
habe das schon mehrfach erzählt hatte
man im grunde gar keine politischen
instrumente aber auch keine erkenntnisse
über das funktionieren des gasmarkts man
muss einfach einräumen dass viele
gesetze die eine trügerische sicherheit
ausgestrahlt haben überhaupt nicht für
diese situation gedacht und geschrieben
waren
vielleicht also ich nehme diese gas
notfallverordnung auf europäischer ebene
die er sagt wir schalten die industrien
hat die letzte verbraucher sind
geschützt
das szenario dass dieser
verordnung zu grunde liegt ist nicht
eine auseinandersetzung eine permanente
auseinandersetzung um eine fossile
energie versorgung sondern vielleicht
eine störung durch unfall also irgend
eine gasleitung geht kaputt und für ein
paar tage ist die versorgungssicherheit
in einer bestimmten regierung nicht
gewährleistet und das macht es natürlich
total sinn zu sagen ja dann fahren wir
halt die industrie prozesse für eine
woche runter das kann der staat
ausgleichen und dann ist die leitung
wieder heilige macht dann geht's wieder
weiter aber frieren soll da keiner für
diese situation die wir jetzt aber haben
ist diese verordnung sagen wir zu
pauschal so war die bundesnetzagentur
die abwehr gesetzt das ist ja ein altes
gesetz als bundes last verteiler für die
notfall stufe 1 treten soll und dann
regulieren soll welche falls die märkte
wirklich versagen welche industrien
welche branchen welche region nicht mehr
mit gas versorgt werden natürlich darauf
angewiesen dass die kenntnisse über die
verbräuche in den regionen hat und über
die energie sparen und wenn man richtig
traf denkt auch kenntnisse über die
lieferketten hätte gar keinen sinn
irgendeinen unternehmens rauszunehmen
weil man denkt man ja das ist vielleicht
entbehrlich und dann danach
festzustellen dass ganze ketten der der
der versorgung von deutschland dadurch
zusammenbrechen diese daten gab es gar
nicht noch nicht mal auf papier und was
die bundesnetzagentur unter hochdruck
macht mit dem
trading hat joop ist diese daten zu
sammeln die daten der unternehmen
einzulegen in eine software die mit
einem algorithmus geführt und dann
ermöglicht je nach szenario die
richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen
diese plattform nutzen wir dann auch um
das mag instrument einzusetzen und
deswegen dauert es halt ein bisschen
länger es ist nicht die schlüssigkeit
der kolleginnen und kollegen die dazu
führt dass wir das erst im sommer
einsetzen können sondern die
schlüssigkeit der jahre zuvor und das
ist der fleiß der kollegin und der
kollegen dienen einer windeseile diese
daten gesammelt haben eine software eine
ein programm gebaut haben programmiert
haben das es uns ermöglicht dann kluge
entscheidungen zu treffen vor allem erst
einmal marktbasierte kluge
entscheidungen zu treffen
man sieht allerdings auch dass
deutschland in der digitalisierung von
prozessen nicht nur beim ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien noch ganz schön
was aufzuholen hat herr wiedemann bitte
ja morgen eine frage dabei jetzt zum
zeitpunkt die jetzt auszurufen warum
haben sie das nicht schon vergangene
woche gemacht denn die gaskrise gegen
jahr seit vergangener woche dienstag
oder mittwoch stark zurück also was
braucht ihr jetzt noch diese
vorbereitung dass sie das heute machen
und ich schon ein paar tage eher
die durchdringung der marktanalyse ich
habe dieses sagen ja gerade erwähnt wir
haben das einmal durchgerechnet und ich
will das noch mal sagen das ist hier
kein spiel das wir spielen das ausrufen
der alarmstufe ist eine
ein schritt der
außergewöhnlich ist
und ich habe darauf hingewiesen dass wir
in der gegenwart also für den tag für
die tage die wir gerade haben genug gas
bekommen und die speicher ja auch zu
nehmen also die speicherstände haben
sich in den letzten vor der reduktion
des gases hatten wir zu namen von 0,8
prozent 0 9 prozent teilweise also fast
knappes prozent jetzt hat er sich
halbiert in den letzten tagen schwanken
zwischen 0,3 und 0,5 den letzten 24
stunden 0,3 der speicherstadt betrieb
jetzt 58,7 prozent also wir nähern uns
langsam der 60 an also wenn man auf dem
ta cook denkt man nach na ja die lage
ist oft trotz der reduktion bewältigt
war
der markt funktioniert gas kommt nach
europa die speicher werden auch langsam
voller langsamer als zuvor wie wir haben
langsam voller und das was uns
alarmieren muss ist die perspektive und
die perspektive haben wir einmal sauber
durchgerechnet und so würde ich es gerne
halten uns nicht durch die irakischen
entscheidungen oder die strategischen
raten entscheidung von putin treiben zu
lassen sondern
möglichst alle szenarien politisch
vorbereitet zu haben und dann auf der
basis von tatsächlichen fakten lagen die
entscheidungen treffen
dann bitte herr grün und danach gehe ich
wieder in den physischen raum
guten morgen er ist christ
ich hätte eine frage ob es kalkulation
in ihrem haus gibt wie stark denn die
preise noch zulegen werden in den
nächsten monaten das ist ein blick in
die glaskugel
aber sie brauchen ja irgend eine
grundannahme um überhaupt auch ist
angebote für die verbraucher und auch
die wirtschaft kalkulieren zu können
es gibt szenarien aber wir sie ist so
wie sie sagen die sind natürlich nicht
sehr verlässlich wir liegen jetzt für
die kalkulation die wir haben den
aktuellen gaspreis zu wohnende plus -
also in dem range indem wir sind ich
glaube es im heute 125 euro dass es
waren schon mal 130 nach der
verkündigung von tieren ist es ein
bisschen runtergegangen auf unser ziel
so schwankt zwischen 110 115 und 130
heute sind 125 der gaspreis war aber
auch schon mal bei 300 euro und ist dann
also bei kriegsbeginn ist dann wieder
runter gegangen also das sind wirklich
große sprünge am markt schwer zu
kalkulieren aber wir nehmen schon einen
höheren wert an
haben auch szenarien natürlich dass die
werte exorbitant hoch gehen natürlich
könnten sie auch theoretisch wieder
runtergehen nicht zu sehr wahrscheinlich
dann wird er wieder in dem physischen
raum frau pinzler zunächst dann herr
drauf hätte und dann
habe ich wie sehr können sie für
deutschland tatsächlich planen da wir ja
zur solidarität mit anderen europäischen
ländern verpflichtet sind wie sehr ihn
das die kalkulation kaputt und auch eine
ganz kurze zweite fragen wie sehr fühlen
sie sich eigentlich allein in der
bundesregierung wo sie immer zum sparen
aufrufen aber die anderen eher steigen
ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht lange in
der bundesregierung sondern bin den
kollegen dankbar dass die den weg
unterstützen dass sie das geld
bereitstellen die gestern 15 milliarden
ist ja auch kein pappenstiel
wurden bewilligt und zwar sowohl vom
finanzministerium wie im
haushaltsausschuss die hilfsprogramme
für die unternehmen die wir aufgestellt
haben alles ist in gutem zusammenspiel
erfolgt und gerade die vorbereitenden
maßnahmen die wir seit dezember
getroffen haben die kenntnisse die wir
erworben haben sind auch im engen
zusammenspiel mit dem kanzleramt
erworben also da es ist eine sehr gute
kooperation und von einsamkeit kann
keine rede sein die
erste folge war
die einen europäischen länder ich habe
schon gesagt im grunde verbietet sich
die frage jetzt hier über nationale
alleingänge nachzudenken gerade für
deutschland denn wir fördern ja nur noch
einen kleinen teil unser gas verbräuche
selbst im eigenen land also darauf
angewiesen dass andere länder durch
leighton beziehungsweise und ihre lng
terminals zur verfügung stellen ohne die
könnten wir gleich einpacken also sind
wir umgekehrt natürlich auch
verpflichtet das was wir an
möglichkeiten haben den europäischen
nachbarn zur verfügung zu stellen die
europäischen nachbarn wiederum sollten
alles an ihrer stelle alles für sie
mögliche tun ebenfalls die
gasverbraucher runterzubringen
beziehungsweise ihrer speicher hoch zu
halten und das ist auch ein signal des
heutigen tages nach europa das
jedenfalls die deutsche bundesregierung
und dieses ministerium und ich in
persona der meinung bin wir müssen noch
besser werden
dann bitte als nächstes hätte
für die
energieversorgungssicherheit ist
entscheidend dass diese zwei ersten
terminals gebaut werden und da hört man
dass die planung jetzt nicht so voran
schreitet das
dass sie da zufrieden sein können stimmt
das und was machen sie oder hat
möglicherweise jetzt auch diese
ausrufung der alarmstufe noch mal ein
bisschen mehr die nachdrücklichkeit
unterstrichen
wir begleiten die planung und den bau
eng und es geht auch gut voran wichtig
ist dass immer wieder konkrete einzelne
probleme auftreten sobald wir davon zu
hören
bekommen lösen wie sie
dann mit der herold
nochmal zur preisanpassungsklausel wie
weit sind wir aus ihrer sicht von einer
strukturellen gas mangel lage noch
entfernt und gibt es andere szenarien
aus dass nord stream 1 auf 0 prozent
versorgung runtergeht dass es zu dieser
strukturellen mangel lage kommt die
strukturelle mangel lage ist daran
gebunden dass wir die versorgung nicht
mehr sicherstellen können in deutschland
da sind wir also noch länger von
entfernt in der realität
dass vorsorge paradox greift hier ein
stück weit um diese realität nicht
eintreten zu lassen also im winter ein
szenario wir sagen jetzt müssen wir
abschalten bzw wir haben tatsächlich zu
wenig gas um die versorgungssicherheit
in deutschland zu gewährleisten müssen
wir jetzt vorsorge treffen obwohl noch
genug da gas da ist obwohl ja niemand
der bei seinem verstand ist jetzt seine
wohnung oder sein haus heißt deswegen
diese im gewissen sinne
widersprüchliche situation im moment ist
alles gut aber der moment darf nicht
darüber hinwegtäuschen dass wenn wir im
moment verharren alles schlecht wird und
deswegen werden wir über die
verschiedenen gesetze das ausrufen der
alarmstufe
unseren teil dazu beitragen dass dieses
vorsorge paradoxon aufgelöst wird dass
wir uns nicht in einer trügerischen
sicherheit wägen und danach feststellen
das hätten wir mal lieber nicht tun
sollen aber natürlich das ist mir völlig
klar wir arbeiten am ende gegen die
menschliche allzumenschliche
erwartungshaltung an das schließt mich
ein und ich glaube jeder weiß dass von
sich selbst dass man so reden wie ich
das hier halte von politikern irgendwie
da rein daraus wird und sagt na ja aber
jetzt gehe ich raus und für geehrt
werden und dann hat man wieder vergessen
was eigentlich gerade phase ist und
diese diese vergesslichkeit diese selbst
eigentlich hätten wir alle in uns haben
die ist unser größter feind und die
müssen wir jetzt versuchen aufzubrechen
ich glaube durch eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung also nicht durch den
appell jeder muss sondern wir alle
können
dann bitte wieder in den digitalen raum
herr skupin herr bollmann und dann happy
es gehe
vielen dank herr habe ich noch eine
frage zum energie sicherungs gesetz die
sagten ja vorhin so kommentiert noch
nicht können die preise erhöht sofort
werden heißt das sie rechnen für die
nächsten tage wochen damit und was
eigentlich die voraussetzungen jetzt
noch mal konkret dass das passiert noch
einmal in die preise werden erhöht und
zwar regulär und ich würde sagen und
abwendbar denn die höheren energiekosten
sind ja nicht erst in der zukunft dar
sondern haben mir schon stattgefunden
und die energieversorgungsunternehmen
geben sie an die kunden weiter auch die
industrie gibt wo sie kann die preise an
die kunden weiter das schild ja zu der
hohen inflation
das worüber geräten ist eine sprunghafte
oder plötzliche sofortige weitergabe
innerhalb der bestehenden verträge sie
verträgt man kann quasi als
versorgungsunternehmen aus den verträgen
heraus treten und sagen ich habe so hohe
kosten die kann ich nicht mehr tragen
dann fällig um dann über liebe ich das
nicht mehr als unternehmen und dann gebe
ich es an die verbraucher weiter und
diese situation kann passieren das habe
ich schon ausgeführt die viele
energieversorgungsunternehmen machen im
moment - weil sie ihre verträge bedienen
müssen aber die verträge sind günstiger
als die einkaufsmengen das nicht daran
dass zumindest wenn sie sich auf
russisches gas verlassen haben dies ja
nun reduziert ist also müssen sie die
mengen am spot markt einkaufen damit
machen sie mit der erfüllung ihrer
verträge ein - wenn ich habe auch schon
jeweils angedeutet was das politische
risiko ist wenn ein gasversorgung oder
ein energieversorgungsunternehmen nicht
mehr am markt bestehen kann dann geht es
nicht mehr um dieses unternehmen alleine
sondern um den markt selbst und wie weit
wieder von den fern sind es spekulation
aber es ist jedenfalls bei den hohen
preisen und bei der politischen lage in
der wir uns befinden ein szenario das
wir sehr ernst nehmen
dann bitte herr bäumen
guten morgen ich habe zwei kurze fragen
dass eine bezieht sich auch die
internationale dimension die sich auch
schon ein paar mal gestrafft haben mit
blick auf mögliche lieferländer wie usa
oder auch andere länder die ist nicht in
der ähnliche notlage vielleicht in
deutschland befinden italien zum
beispiel
erwarten sie da irgendwelche beschlüsse
jetzt von den anstehenden gipfeltreffen
eu g7 was sozusagen westliche energie
solidarität betrifft wenn ich das mal so
pathetisch ausdrücken darf und die
zweite frage ist wir haben jetzt auch
schon ein paar mal über preise
gesprochen
inwieweit erhalten sie ist es möglich
dass der bund der staat die gaspreise
sozusagen schon an der quelle
subventioniert im grunde diese 15
milliarden zu speichern sind ja wenn man
es recht betrachtet eigentlich schon der
der einstieg in so eine gastro fans
dankeschön die 15 milliarden die wir
jetzt am markt besorgen liegen darin
begründet dass einige unternehmen nicht
mehr die liquidität haben die gasmengen
am markt zu besorgen das gilt natürlich
vor allem für die töchter von gazprom
germania die jetzt nicht mehr gazprom
germania heißt sondern energy security
früher wenn ich das richtig weiß
die ja die müssten ja quasi rubel von
putin bekommen um die deutschen
energiemarkt zu versorgen das ist ja
sanktioniert und findet nicht mehr statt
dann hängen aber hinter der tochter
wingas beispielsweise viele stadtwerke
wenn die kein geld mehr bekommen vom
eigentümer gas kommen noch immer dann
muss halt jemand anderes einspringen
dieses geld ist allerdings keine
subvention ist auch nicht weg sondern
wird ja ein gas angelegt und mit einer
ich würde sagen sehr sehr hohen
wahrscheinlichkeit wird es dann
irgendwann gebraucht werden zu den
preisen die dann eben am markt erzielt
werden das ist also ein beitrag zur
liquidität kein geschenk es wird wieder
reinkommen und die darlehen laufzeit ist
gebunden an ende 25
also dieses geld ist keine subvention
sondern eine
notwendige maßnahme
des staates dafür zu sorgen dass genug
geld da ist die speicher zu fühlen und
voll zu kriegen und trading hamburg die
das geld verwalten sind dann auch nicht
in der konkurrenz zu den unternehmen
sondern sie nehmen die
scheiben in den speichern die nicht
durch markt gefüllt werden also reden
vor allem gazprom eigentümer
bezieht aber auch andere speicher können
sie eintreten wenn sie sehen dass dort
die gesetzliche speicherverpflichtung
nicht ausgeübt werden oder werden können
also das ist er das sagen die füllung
der marktlücke aber keine subventionen
ansonsten
denke ich dass wir insgesamt
lernen und für das vielleicht auch schon
vor hinweise gab dass ein eingriff in
den preis
nie die beste alternative ist weil die
preis wirkung natürlich auch dazu
beiträgt dass effizienzen gehoben werden
das soll nicht zynisch klingen weil ich
ja weiß unterstreicht das noch einmal
wie sehr menschen und unternehmen
darunter leiden dass die preise so hoch
sind aber würde man die preise
abschneiden oder würde man die hälfte
der preise oder irgendeine summe
subventionieren und sagen dann ist es
nicht mehr so teuer
würde man ja das fatale signal setzen
macht einfach weiter wie bisher
um die preiseffekte abzufedern ist eine
gezielte unterstützung der unternehmen
und der bürgerinnen und bürger der
verbrauchern und verbraucher die es
brauchen das politisch bessere
instrument
ich würde jetzt noch drei fragen dran
nehmen und zwar die kolleginnen und
kollegen die sich die noch nicht dran
kamen die weiteren fragen würde ich dann
gerne auf den hintergrund verweisen mit
staatssekretär gleichen und klaus müller
chef der bundesnetzagentur
die stehen auch gleich noch zu für
fragen zur verfügung
deswegen jetzt bitte herbst ihm dann
frau hülsen und dann malte kreutzfeldt
bitte und danach würden wir uns dann im
hintergrund wieder sehen
können sie sagen vielleicht sie haben
von den berechnungen den gesprochen
innenministerium können sie sagen dann
kommt dazu eine rationierung des
gases für die industrie können sie das
vielleicht
voraussehen in welchem monat soweit
kommen wird bin ich
nur sagen hoffentlich nie wenn das ist
ein politisches szenario wo es keine
richtigen entscheidung mehr gibt sondern
vielleicht nur weniger falsche all die
maßnahmen sind darauf ausgerichtet dass
wir die marktkräfte so weit wie es geht
wirksam halten und andere alternativen
schaffen einsparungen andere
energieträger ausbau von infrastruktur
um dieses szenario abzuwenden
das soll nicht es soll nicht passieren
in keinem monat im besten fall ich kann
es natürlich nicht ausschließen weil es
so voraussetzung des reiches was wir tun
aber es ist kein szenario auf das wir
hinarbeiten im gegenteil frau hülsen
bitte und dann malte kreutzfeldt
guten morgen eine frage noch mal zum
artikel 24 wird es jetzt die aufgabe der
kommenden wochen seien entlastungen zu
finden für den moment in dem der artikel
24 dann auch gezogen wird oder ist es
auch eine erwägung den artikel 24 selbst
nochmal anzufassen und die mechanischen
hin zu ändern die darin bisher
vorgesehen sind für die preis weiteren
habe
der artikel 24 oder § 24 ist ich habe
schon gesagt ein sehr scharfes schwert
er ist an die voraussetzungen gebunden
dass die bundesnetzagentur
nach einer längeren betrachtung der
machtverhältnisse die gas notlage dann
aus ruft in deutschland und für alles
würde ich sagen dass wir in einem
prozess uns befinden
wo wir immer neu lernen das heißt ich
will für kein gesetz dass wir gemacht
haben
sagen das ist jetzt das letzte mal dass
wir ein gesetz angefasst haben wir sind
ja auch gedanklich in einem bereich wo
noch niemand vorher war und
deswegen ist die erwartungshaltung die
manchmal auch im politischen raum
geäußert wird da gibt es die eine große
lösung den einen großen gipfel falsch
der gipfel ist eine permanente arbeit
die krisenbewältigung ist ein
permanentes arbeiten mit den
verschiedenen unternehmen den
vertretungen den verbraucher vertreterin
kapazität an die kollegen aus den
ländern in der koalition
und so sind auch jetzt diese tage also
ich rede mit in den konferenzen mit den
energieministern dem ländern mit der
wirtschaft mit den energieversorgern mit
dem verbraucher vertreterin bald so
ergeben sich natürlich jede menge neue
erkenntnisse und ich will das für mich
sagen ich brauche diese kollektive
kreativität oder wir brauchen diese
konnektivität um immer besser zu werden
und wenn wir das ministerium auch meine
person immer fokussiert sind auf die
dinge über die wir jetzt in ihrer
pressekonferenz geredet haben wir sehen
wir vielleicht an anderer stelle
gesetzes normen möglichkeiten noch
andere
elemente zu heben die in anderen
fachbereichen liegen also brauche ich
den zuruf von bürgerinnen und bürgern
von den kollegen aus den ländern oder
auch von den kollegen im kabinett die
sagen da kann es auch noch was machen
und es gibt solche sachen alle ihr tag
gestern hat mich auch drei oder vier
neue gesetzesinitiativen gebracht
nämlich nicht weiß ob sie tragen aber
die ist am haus abgearbeitet werden
insofern glaube ich müssen wir einfach
nur so ehrlich sein dass wir hier in
einer gemeinsamen lernen bewegung uns
befinden und die macht uns besser
meinte kreutzfeldt zum abschluss bitte
vielen dank
während sie gas notlage ausrufen ist ja
werden andererseits jeden tag in
deutschland auf neue gasheizung in
wohnungen und häuser eingebaut sie
hatten ja da habe ich bei dem
koalitionsgipfel im märz schon versucht
dieses verbot von neuen gasheizung
vorzuziehen sind damit aber gescheitert
gibt es denn da jetzt überlegungen dass
man in einer solchen situation wie jetzt
auch das vielleicht nochmal anfasst und
keine neuen gasverbraucher ans netz
nimmt der alarmstufe die wir heute
ausrufen die notfall stufe wäre dann der
nächste schritt nur dass das nicht die
katholisch durcheinander geht es ist
tatsächlich so dass ab 2024 so dass der
letzte der vorletzte koalitionsausschuss
verabredet die der anteil der
erneuerbaren energien im wärmebereich
bei 65 prozent liegen muss das sind ganz
häufig ist wird ein paar mal
techniken geben aber ganz häufig dann
werden die dann je nach anteil der
erneuerbaren energien elektrisch geführt
einen anteil der erneuerbaren zum
betrieb haben die frage ob man das noch
weiter vorziehen kann es letztlich eine
frage ob der markt das bewältigen kann
wir haben demnächst einen wärmepumpen
gipfel zusammen mit der kollegin klara
geywitz der versucht die umstellung im
markt erst einmal stärker anzuregen mein
eindruck ist dass das was wir im moment
erleben eine totale trendumkehr ist sehr
viele
installationsbetriebe sind ja auf
gasheizung spezialisiert gewesen ich
will nicht sagen die königs anderes aber
sie müssen sich erstmal darauf
einstellen dass das was gestern noch
gewollt und ja bis zum antritt dieser
regierung auch politisch gefördert wurde
dass das jetzt nicht mehr richtig ist
und deswegen ist die umstellung die
umstellung findet jetzt schon stadt
gesetzlich dann ab 24 normiert ich weiß
gar nicht ob das weitere vorziehen zu
einem sofortigen effekt kommen würde
jedenfalls politisch noch nicht
vereinbart
einsatz finde ich noch sagen das habe
ich vorhin übersprungen die frage nach
europäischer kooperation wenn ich das
noch sagen darf das ist natürlich im g 7
gipfel und beim rat wo alles geredet
wird etwas anderes als bei den
fachministerkonferenz die wir dann ab
montag und dienstag in luxemburg haben
aber ich habe schon darauf hingewiesen
dass wir zur in besser in einem
gemeinsamen markt sind und deswegen wäre
natürlich erstens ist notwendig dass man
die gemeinsamen leitungen die
infrastruktur zusammen entwickelt und
barrieren auf hebt das gilt für den gas
später wasserstoff bereich aber auch
natürlich für den strombereich zweitens
und das ist geht
will ich noch mal unterstreichen ist der
beschleunigte ausbau von
energieeffizienzmaßnahmen und
erneuerbaren energien ein großer teil
der lösung und der findet übrigens statt
man guckt jetzt auf die oberfläche
jemand sieht durch meine
presseankündigung ob es muss auch noch
kohlekraftwerke wieder anmachen und lng
terminals bauen und das ist die
oberfläche und sie ist eine zerbeulte
zerkratzte ganz schwierige oberflächen
auch keine die mich glücklich geschweige
denn stolz macht unterhalb der
oberfläche registrieren wir eine
wahnsinnige dynamik bei der sanierung
von häusern bei den investitionen der
unternehmen die alle schneller ihre
klimaneutralität projekte vorziehen
wollen als es jemals gedacht war das
heißt dass die europäische kooperation
die eigentliche dynamik unter der
oberfläche die so schwierig ist moment
unterstützen muss nicht ab wirkung aus
sondern mit gesetzen mit
förderstrukturen mit den notwendigen
maßnahmen den projekten beispielsweise
aber auch schnellen genehmigen
unterstützen muss und auch das können
wir natürlich in diesem halben jahr noch
schaffen da wo wir noch wärme durch
nutzung von abwärme nutzung von
abwasserwärme nutzung von biogas anlagen
nutzen von solarthermie reduzieren
können das sollten wir es tun und noch
mal
die summe von vielen kleinen maßnahmen
hilft dann am ende fiel
vielen dank vielen dank dass sie so
kurzfristig zu dieser pressekonferenz
gekommen sind
gutes gelingen beim schreiben beim
umsetzen und ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen tag noch ist zu lang
soweit meine damen und herren so weit
der bundeswirtschaftsminister zur lage
auf den gasmärkten und sie sehen wir
sind jetzt auch im sogenannten linearen
fernsehen wie